this is it the last confrontation we
talk about today's the day you stop
cicada
something is struggling to break through
or someone
Don
I need to know we're not making this
worse tell me you know what you're doing
stay with the plan
follow my instructions defeat cicada
it'll destroy his dagger and then
we will save your father
[Music]
everybody is Charlie this is gonna be my
new flash reverse flash trailer for
episode 16
so obviously the focus is here on two
different storylines reverse flash and
Nora completely screwing the timeline in
the future and then trying to give the
key to the cure in present day I have a
couple of theories about what reverse
flash is talking about because of all
the godspeed stuff that's happening in a
couple episodes that's only a couple
weeks away
we also learned more about what's
happening during crisis on Infinite
Earths later this year because we
learned that they're going to end the
arrow TV show right after a crisis so it
all ties together all this stuff that
reverse-flash and Nora are planning and
messing with the timeline so we'll break
it down there's a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
flash comment on the video the title of
the episode is failure is an orphan and
that's actually based on the quote
victory has a hundred fathers and defeat
is an orphan it just means that many
people will seek credit for success but
very few people will accept
responsibility for failure so obviously
you're talking about the two different
storylines like reverse flash doesn't
sound like someone who would be willing
to accept failure and then obviously you
have the cicada stuff in present-day
within trying to give him the cure the
description of the episode just reads
with the metahuman cure ready to use
barry and team flash muffs figure out a
way to subdue cicada long enough to take
it killer frost steps in to help with
the plan meanwhile Joe eases back into
work and Nora isn't happy about the way
the flash plans to stop cicada in the
reverse flash scene he's looking at all
that time language saying that something
is trying to break through the timeline
or someone the episode after this one is
called time bomb and then the episode
after that episode 18 is called Godspeed
so it sounds like God speed or the
introduction of god speed has something
to do with what reverse flash is talking
about also on top of that you have to
remember Stephen Amell confirmed their
ending arrow after the final ten
episodes of arrow season eight before
the end of the year so between the
changes reverse flash and noir are
making to the timeline the metaphor of a
time bomb the advent of God speed on the
show and the green arrows bargain with
the monitor something that Nora and
reverse-flash do has something to do
with crisis on Infinite Earths happening
much much earlier in the timeline than
it originally did during Nora's future
newspapers and to Oliver Queen is the
that disappears during crisis then you
get the arrow series finale is a sort of
epilogue to crisis on Infinite Earths so
I think the whole idea here when you
really look at what's going on is that
noir in reverse-flash are ultimately
successful because that's all she cares
about is saving her father she's not
really thinking about other
reverse-flash stuff that he might be
planning on his own but none of that
says anything about how things change
for either of them in their timelines
because season one reverse-flash
eobard thawne still originally thought
that Nora was one of the tornado twins
from the comics Barry's true twin
children mean that whatever they've done
to screw the timeline before this season
they've already baby Sarah Diggle
themselves into a situation whereby one
of the twins just disappears she doesn't
have a brother in this timeline jesse
chambers
no baby Lauren wait Danica William it
doesn't matter oh she is
is your daughter
you've brought me your daughter
it's uh
dawn so when further altering things to
save bury along the way to crisis on
Infinite Earths they also probably
caused the changes that bring back
Nora's brother so to speak remember even
during season 5 they're still paying off
berries gibberish future time language
that he's been speaking when he came out
of the speedforce
at the beginning of season 4 episode 1
in one of those lines was we're gonna
need more diapers and they still haven't
paid that off yet that probably has
something to do with the tornado twins
and these continued changes on route 2
this accelerated crisis on Infinite
Earths so yay happy moment but also you
still have the looming threat of crisis
and now the imminent disappearance of
Oliver Queen Green Arrow in place of
Barry Allen but you're talking more
about Nora reverse-flash stuff because
the show is trying to get you so
attached to the Nora character like they
really want you to like her so if she
would ever go away you would be really
upset it would be really weird if they
brought her back next season after
making all these changes and she were a
completely different character like yay
we changed the timeline but I'm a
completely different person so if they
pay off that tornado twins twist at the
end of the season and she winds up with
a brother what they might do is just say
that Nora's full name is like Nora dawn
Allen so she still has the dawn name
from the tornado twins in the comics but
it's her middle name and they just do
the same thing for whatever her brother
might wind up being remember they're
rumors that Cisco is going to be leaving
the TV show there are also rumors that
Tom Cavanagh is leaving the TV show as
well which would mean that reverse flash
or his reverse flash would have to
technically leave the show regardless of
whether or not those are true I do think
that eobard thawne Tom Cavanagh reverse
flash will participate in crisis on
Infinite Earths they teased it at the
beginning of the season there's a line
of dialogue in Nora's newspaper that
says reverse-flash scene leading an army
of shadow demons they totally have to
pay that up but if Tom Cavanaugh really
is leaving the show what they might do
is just use crisis as a way to get rid
of him and either introduce godspeed
full-time as a big villain for the show
or just change reverse flashes face so
to speak so that it's a new actor or a
younger version of the character from
before he became Barry Allen's enemy so
even if you keep EU barred Thawne around
it's a very different version of the
character and it doesn't feel like the
exact same story that you've done every
single
season with him I haven't been a really
big fan of the cicada storyline this
season but I think they've done a pretty
good job before shadowing where that's
gonna end up because we know that grace
eventually takes the mantle of cicada in
the future they might just find a way to
show that to current day cicada so that
he's horrified in somehow they find a
way to convince him to take the
metahuman cure and then she gets it too
they go off and they have their happy
ending I know there's still a lot of
questions about what's happening with
arrows final season and whether or not
some of those actors will come to the
flash TV show or the Batwoman TV show
when the show ends because obviously the
characters will continue to exist in the
universe so there will be crossovers but
here's a short clip of Stephen Amell
sort of explaining what's going on with
that towards the end of season 6
I approached Greg Berlanti why I will be
thanking in a second and said that I
thought both personally and
professionally that at the end of my
commitment this coming season it would
be the best for for me to to move on
I've always been a I've always been a
fan of of television shows that not only
don't overstay their welcome but and in
a manner that really packs a punch and
so it had always been my hope that that
we would know when we were gonna finish
this journey and not link to the finish
line so to speak after a lot of
discussion Greg and I decided that the
best way to do this would be to have me
come back for a limited run in season
eight which is what we're gonna do and
from there I had always hoped that
beyond the 17 different shows that that
arrow has spawned I'm kidding it's only
like 16 that that there was a
possibility that the show could live on
beyond beyond me because the entity of
all of the Queen and the character and
the mythos and the iconography of Green
Arrow has always been something that's
bigger than than me or any other actor
that's playing him or voicing him
there's always been something more to it
I spoke with beth schwartz and Marc
Guggenheim
this past Friday and then Greg
brilliantly this past Friday night and
it was the decision of WB and CW and
Beth and Greg and Mark in a very mutual
way based off of of what they thought
was best for the show creatively and and
being very are honorable and respectful
as pertains to to my wishes that we were
gonna end after a 10 episode run next
year
I've already done a video explaining
what I think that they're going to be
doing during the final season about him
disappearing during crisis believe all
your video requests in the comments
below while you wait for everything
click here for my early review of the
Shazam movie in a bunch of new footage
and click here for my Captain Marvel
post-credits scene video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]